la parole est au président Marc Angeli
pour le groupe horizon merci merci
madame la Présidente et merci monsieur
le Président pour votre intervention
votre présence ici nous engage monsieur
le Président et je veux au nom du groupe
horizon et apparenté que je préside vous
réaffirmer tout notre soutien comme j'ai
d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de le faire
chez vous à Kiev en décembre dernier
madame la Première ministre presque un
an après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine
90 ans après la plus grande famine qu'a
connue le pays voici que resurgit le
spectre de l'eau de mort monsieur le
Président en a parlé une nouvelle fois
la Russie menace la sécurité alimentaire
des peuples c'est donc nécessairement
l'affaire de tous
rappelons qu'avant l'invasion russe
l'Ukraine était le quatrième exportateur
mondial de maïs et de blé avec la guerre
la Russie a d'abord imposé un blocus en
mer Noire levé ensuite au prix d'apprent
négociation et d'un contrôle accru sur
les exportations maritimes depuis
s'ajoute au manque de carburant les
dommages continuent sur les
infrastructures de stockage et les
machines agricoles
les agriculteurs sont donc en première
ligne dans ce conflit il a fallu aider
l'Ukraine à écouler sa production malgré
les blocus la France et l'Union
européenne l'ont fait en créant un
corridor de solidarité dont la
logistique a permis de générer 15
milliards d'euros de revenus en Ukraine
mais les capacités de ce dispositif sont
limitées car son coût logistique et les
goulets d'étranglement sont présents
nous le savons pour qu'ils continuent de
porter ses fruits des investissements
supplémentaires devront être consentis
en plus de cela l'Union européenne
finance avec l'organisation pour
l'alimenter à l'agriculture un programme
de soutien pour les agriculteurs
Ukrainiens face à l'invasion russe
l'aide militaire est une nécessité à
court terme mais nous devons aussi nous
engager pour que ce conflit n'aggrave
pas une famine mondiale déjà fortement
accrue par les sécheresses sur le
continent africain madame la Première
ministre si à nouveau blocus devait
s'engager en mer Noire comment
pouvons-nous améliorer et pérenniser les
corridors de solidarité pouvons-nous
envisager d'autres programmes de soutien
aux agriculteurs Ukrainiens je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président